The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
Tucker Carlson interview on full send uh
yes I saw um I didn't watch the entire
thing but I saw a few clips of it when
he's talked about uh how much he regrets
supporting the Warner act as we
referring to yeah yeah and I believe him
I think he really means it I believe him
sometimes you know sometimes there's
people like there's like John McCain
types who go like you know or Hillary
Clinton they'll admit
okay it was a mistake but then they
still support every subsequent war after
that and they know it doesn't see
whereas Tucker is like I'm so ashamed
that I supported this I'll never forgive
myself for it and has opposed every
subsequent war after that and I'm like
okay I think this guy really believes it
he's different than people want to
pretend he is first of all the guy was a
deadhead
yeah you know that he's just follow the
dead around yeah so for sure dropped
acid all right that'd be my guess I
would how how else can you enjoy the
music I oh I think it's legally required
that you've taken as of at least once if
you're going to enjoy the Grateful Dead
I'm not sure I don't know
live to LSD according to my friends
who've been there and done that it's
it's really interesting what the um the
public perception of Tucker Carlson is
or or particularly how uh polarizing he
is to people that it's almost it's
almost like you're they're describing a
different person than he actually is
um I really I think he was the most
interesting person in cable news the
most thoughtful most intelligent like he
was really he um I don't agree with him
on anything you know on my uh on my
podcast we used to do a segment or was
this it was I had just done it so many
times that we started joking about it
being a segment that we called Contra
Carlson because I was just disagreeing
with him like he had all these economic
ideas that I completely disagree with
and I disagree with a lot of stuff he
said but he was like
such like the the lone voice in like
really the corporate press who was
completely opposed to the military index
industrial complex completely opposed to
Big Pharma and all of the covet Insanity
it was really good on like speaking up
about a lot of really important issues
issues that you would think like a good
leftist would at least appreciate that
he's good on that issue you know and
some some of them did this is what he's
the guy who's having Glenn Greenwald on
his show you know what I mean he's the
guy who's having Aaron mate and Jimmy
Dore yes this is our right Wingers he's
having like that he's having them and
the
it was very interesting he wasn't a
partisan he would be completely against
the Republican party was viciously
critical of the Republican Party hates
the Republican establishment and even
the stuff I see I've seen so many people
be like um you know he was uh he bought
into Trump's uh claims that the election
was stolen and I'm like I don't know
dude do you watch him because I watch
his show and that's actually not he was
the guy he took a lot of heat from this
from right Wingers that immediately
following the election of 2020. he
really aggressively called out Trump's
lawyers uh Rudy Giuliani and uh Sydney
uh Powell I think was the other one
because they were making claims about
the Dominion voting machines that they
flipped millions of votes and Tucker
girls and went on a show and he goes
okay if this is true it's the biggest
story in the history of the United
States of America so what evidence do
you have
and he's like we have reached out
privately to the Trump's lawyers we've
gotten nothing in return so to be clear
they're making this claim and providing
nothing to back it up he really was like
no no now what he has said later is
they'll be like they'll pull quotes and
be like yeah but he referred to uh 2020
as a scam or something like that and
it's like yeah but you don't watch his
show so you don't get that like what he
was saying was yeah the Dominion vote
flipping thing is [__] no one's ever
provided any evidence of that but the
fact that big Tech and the intelligence
agencies work together to undermine the
hunter Biden story to get Joe Biden
across the finish line is [__] like
that you know what I mean that's a scam
and he's that's a completely reasonable
position to take again it's just you
know like look at this dude Don Lemon is
out at CNN right
promise you whoever replaces Don Lemon
has the same exact views as Don Lemon
and the same exact views of everybody
else at CNN and that's not true for
Tucker Carlson right like there's at
least there was a guy out there who like
would disagree with the with uh the rest
of the people at his Network yeah
disagree with both political parties
he's really designed for the internet I
hope I hope he goes there he's going to
unless they've paid him off to like the
I mean if I was a person in a position
of power in a a wild card like Tucker
Carlson got released from Fox News and
maybe Rumble makes a deal with him or
something like that do you have any
[__] idea how big that would be a
show it could make that that app it
could make that that platform I mean if
Tucker Carlson goes over there it'll be
worth it for them to invest a
considerable amount of money and but if
I was Fox News that's the last thing I
would want so I would make sure that we
have him locked up for the entire term
of some contract some some no compete
and pay them off you'd be better off
just giving him the same amount of money
he made when he was on the air well and
I wonder him opposing you I wonder what
he's already under contract for you know
what I mean like there may already be
some clause in his contract that says
you know if we leave there's x amount of
time I don't know [__] Fox News man
they're smart they're not stupid oh
that's very shocking seeing him leave
yes I was I was surprised although in
Heist one of those things where like I
was surprised right away and then like
two days later I'm like how was he ever
even there like how would this guy was
on the 8 PM hour at Fox News saying the
CIA killed Kennedy you're like how is
that ever a real thing you know like
it's like you say that it's insane he
was like it but what's crazy to me is
that like so many progressives have like
it's like it's like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers or something it's like is this
the real you man have you just been
replaced with an NPC the 8 P.M hour at
Fox news is saying the CIA killed
Kennedy that's not interesting to you
right that's not like some like I'm not
saying you have to agree with him on
everything but like that's not kind of
that's different than Bill O'Reilly yeah
that's a different this is a different
world we're living in now